Neil welcome to the podcast glad to have
you on Rooks
could you introduce yourself sure hey
I'm Neil I do mechanistic
interpretability research which means I
take neural networks by trying to open
them up and stare at the internals and
try to reverse engineer Alps what
algorithms they've learned and
attempting to take us from the world
where we know that a network is good at
a task knowing how the network is good
at the tops and this is really weird of
hard but also kind of fascinating
um and I'm currently a grant supported
independent researcher working on this
stuff I previously worked at anthropic
under Chris Ola who
my opinion basically founded the field
that's a debatable claim
and yeah excited to be here generally
giving hot takes and trying to be
helpful
fantastic so how did you get into this
career where did you start could you
tell us your story of say your education
and how you got into AI safety and
mechanistic interpretability
sure so my childhood is heavily marked
by far too much time spent doing pure
mats I was very into doing math
olympiads when I was in high school was
on the UK's International Mass Olympia
team that's naturally flowed into doing
maths at Cambridge and being really
really into doing the hardest your math
courses I could and then uh towards the
end of my degree I was getting
increasingly burnt out on doing things
that were pretty and Abstract but
fundamentally kind of useless
and I had gotten pretty into effective
altruism
um both via my University society and
when I was much younger uh reading
things like less wrong or Harry Potter
and the methods of rationality which
holds a very special place in my heart
and uh yeah I was originally planning on
going into Finance but sent me the last
minute decided that aixris just seemed
really important I was good at technical
things and could probably maybe do
something useful here and was kind of
confused at risk-averse but decided it
was worth spending at least a year
trying to investigate one Earth was up
in the fields do I think I can do
anything useful
I spent a year doing a bunch of
back-to-back internships at some
different laps and
really Vibe with any of the exact things
I was working on
but by the end of that had concluded
okay something here matters I believe
there is important work to be done I do
not confidently believe that the people
working those already have things
completely hand unsolved
seems like I should obviously just
continue trying to find the best way to
contribute to this
then I massively lucked out and got this
amazing opportunity to work with Chris
Ola at anthropic
um where he'd previously done a bunch of
work reverse engineering image
classifying models
and
topic was listening startup he'd
co-founded where he was working on
reverse engineering language models and
I was kind of involved in the early
stages of that field and this was just
fascinating
uh I think it kind of appeals to
multiple sides of my personality there's
the mathematical computer science loving
abstraction site where you've got this
network fundamentally it is a
mathematical object that is the stack of
a bunch of linear algebra and which I
can just reason about on a conceptual
level and I know all the moving parts
and how it works
it also appeals to my uh truth seeking
side because I am trying hard to form
true beliefs about this model it's
really really easy to trick yourself
hands to come up with a elaborate
complicated elegant hypothesis when
actually there's something really boring
going on
like
you uh think that there's some
special structure of the input that
needs to be there that the model is
picking up on and you just try giving it
some like random other input and it does
the same thing
and it kind of also appeals to the part
of me that likes empiricism and feedback
because the gap between I have an
experiment idea to test a belief about a
model and I just write code and get
feedback it's just incredibly short and
Incredibly satisfying
and this means that I can just iterate
and form true beliefs in this delight
could we go back to the thing you said
about being risk averse so how did that
come about and how did you perhaps
overcome it to choose to engage with
this field
I don't even know how it came about I
think just personality wise I'm a fairly
risk-averse person
things like
does this feel like a kind of somewhat
stable life path
uh does the seem like it's kind of
somewhat socially legible like people
think it's kind of cool and worth caring
about uh does this feel like something I
could imagine myself doing for several
years
um and where I not like afraid that the
rug will suddenly be pulled out from
under me
um this just kind of feels like a pretty
big part of my personality
so it's kind of entertaining that I've
ended up as a grant supported
independent researcher
um but I think things which have shifted
so I think that there are some ways in
which being a bit conservative and a bit
risk-averse can be helpful like a
classic mistake among uh impulsive young
men is well you know young people in
general is have a wild crazy idea you
take really seriously and do something
high risk and throw yourself into it
entirely without checking is this a
terrible idea
and often the desire to be risk-averse
of protecting something but also
often the world is kind of wrong about
important things
um
like I don't know
um most people in January 2020 thought
that covert wasn't a big deal uh some of
the people who thought it was a big deal
also the people I know who think yeah
extras matters the most
and
I think it's important I've tried to
become the kind of person you can notice
when the desire to be socially
conformist or risk-averse is Take Me
Away From what I think is actually
important
and I think the arguments that
human level AI is a thing that could
happen that it's going to be a really
really big deal and will not by default
be a good thing just seem really
compelling even if that kind of weird
one thing that's helped a lot is just
being intentional about the Social
Circles I hang out in and who I talk to
and just having lots of friends who are
also working on these problems makes the
socially conformist part of me a lot
more comfortable because lots of really
smart people I know think that AI
experts calls him assets this is
obviously a double-edged sword
since I know if you hang out with people
who all believe a certain thing it's
very hard to tell if that thing is just
complete BS but
I think that
making sure that I do spend time around
people who share my values and who
reinforce the kind of person I want to
be has felt like a pretty good trade
overall
do you think you reduced your
uncertainty that say AI could become
human level or that AI could lead to
human extinction or did you think more
in terms of how important it would be if
you know what's at stake so did you did
you think about the stakes or did you
think of did you reduce your say
empirical uncertainty about AI what was
most important
I would say both feel pretty important
honestly a lot of the personal decisions
were dominated by OHA I find Working on
mechanistic interpretability really fun
and I seem good at it
such that it doesn't really matter
whether I think AIX risk is a big deal
versus an overwhelmingly enormous deal
uh it seems like the best a really
important problem that I'm unusually
well suited to work on
so just finding things fun rather than
weird abstracts and kind of
guilt-flavored was pretty important
and I think just actually working on
stuff finding it fun and getting
feedback from the world but I was good
at it was probably the most important
thing there
I do think engaging more with the
arguments just talking with more people
for whom
this is actually a significant belief
that has changed how they're living
their life or what they're working on
helped make things feel more real
kind of in a similar way to how I don't
know thinking about trolley problems
feels like a very abstract thing when
forming moral beliefs to me while
um actually thinking through moral
decisions in my life and where I donate
money where I can do the most good is
much more visceral
I think that
actually thinking through day-to-day
research decisions uh what I want to
spend my career on and the way those are
grounded in these beliefs made a little
more visceral which just matters
emotionally if my factual beliefs don't
change
I think I did change my mind on some
empirical things in particular I now
feel like I've got a much more coherent
story for a path by which we get from
where we are now to a world where we
have human level Ai and a world where we
do not have human level AI that is
aligned with what we want
and this is a pretty important part of
taking AIX risk seriously
but that feels kind of secondary to the
more emotional things which maybe makes
me a bad rationalist but
I think people often undervalue these
and over value kind of hot cold hard
logic
so how attractive is a mechanistic
interpretability as a field for a person
that's very into pure mathematics uh say
mathematical Elegance how how developed
is the math in in mechanistic
interpretability compared to other areas
of mathematics
so
I would say that it's
not really an area where there's really
deep and sophisticated mathematical
Theory though there's enough
mathematical things that's useful to be
able to think clearly about having a
mass background is useful actually also
recently worked on a project with one of
my mentees where we reverse engineered
small networks trained to do group
composition which is a kind of intro
level maths course and we discovered it
had this algorithm involving
representation Theory which is a kind of
uh more involved early grad school level
pure maths course
and uh this is a really cool
investigation where both of us having
Mass backgrounds is really helpful uh
but in general
um
yeah I'd say the main things you need to
know are just models are heavily based
on linear algebra multiplying pixels by
matrices having a really really deep
understanding of how to think about this
and reasoning through problems in linear
algebra and also problems in probability
Theory calculus and information Theory
which maybe the other things that feel
most relevance but
I think so I think I really enjoyed peel
maths and I really enjoy mechanistic
interpretability but to me it feels more
like a transfer of flavor than a
transfer of specific domain knowledge
like day to day I am thinking about a
mathematical constructs of a neural
network that is a massive super linear
algebra
I'm trying to reason about what kinds of
functions could be expressed inside the
super linear algebra
and then I'm being a truth-seeking
empiricist who runs experiments to check
for this
and
this kind of iterative truth-seeking
while also reasoning through
abstractions and trying to form true
beliefs about a complex system is part
of what I loved about pure maths and
solving hard math problems or reasoning
through a theorem it's not what everyone
enjoys about it
I also should emphasize that there's
lots of people who do great Mac and tup
work uh that's right short for
mechanistic interpretability and is much
less of a mouthful
uh there are people who do great Mecca's
up work who do not have mass backgrounds
some aren't taking videos but as a pure
mathematician that's kind of what I Vibe
with about it
I feel like it's still a bit abstract
what it is that you actually do so if we
if we try to think about in in very
down-to-earth terms when when you're
looking at the screen in your day-to-day
work what it what what are you looking
at are you are you visualizing the
weights of the network are you yeah how
does it look for you when you work
so the feel of the work is
Well when things are going well the feel
of the work is but I'm in this tight
feedback loop where
so
I have this model the model has some
behavior that it can do
and I'm trying to reverse engineer how
it does this behavior and why it does it
um a concrete example is uh this
uh there was this great paper for
anthropic I was vaguely involved with on
induction heads which uh a a
small part of a language model
uh we often use the term circuit to
refer to a kind of sub part of a model
doing a specific task that's part of the
model's overall what it's doing
um so induction heads this tiny circuit
which it detects and continues repeated
text
for example uh if you've got a
um if there's an article about Gus
docker
and the name Gus comes up followed by
Docker in the past
um so the way language models are
trained they're trained to predict what
comes next
uh like what's the next words so when it
sees Gus it checks what where was Gus in
the past what came after that Docker
Docker should come next
and so I'd take a model with some
Behavior I want to interrogate like this
oh it knows that Docker comes next if
glass Docker came in the past
and then I try to understand how it does
this
and there's a talkative of different
techniques I might use for this
um one of the
simplest is this idea called direct
logic attribution where there's a bit of
jargon but it basically means is the
model has this output called logits
which represent How likely it thinks
each next word is to arise
and uh this is a
linear function of what each bit of the
model has output where the important bit
of linear function is it means you can
break this down into what was
contributed by each bit of the model
and I can just check which bits the
model most contributed to the fact that
it thought Docker came next
and then plot a picture where each
component is colored by how Dockery it
was
and that's like one example of the thing
I might be doing day to day as the first
step
yes yes tell me if you like this analogy
so when you're looking at a neural
network perhaps that's somewhat
analogous to the brain and then you're
trying to understand which parts of the
network are responsible for which
functions perhaps somewhat analogously
to how the brain different regions of
the brain are responsible for different
functions of the human body or the
speech center or the center for balance
something like this how how well does
that analogy work
it's okay
uh I think that the neural networks are
basically like human brains thing is
pretty overblown
though I do think digital Neuroscience
is a reasonable enough handle on what
mechanistic interpretability is
one of in part I think just the name
neural network is really misleading
because it sounds like oh super
brain-like where if you look at the
actual internal function of networks
that are wildly different from our
brains in a bunch of ways like in a
network every neuron is connected to
every neuron in the next layer uh what's
called being dense well our brain's a
sparse and generally in our brains
neurons are either firing or not firing
while inside the model how much it fires
is like a really really important thing
and I'm not a neuroscientist so it's
very plausible that a lot of what I'm
saying is just Raw
which is also part of why I don't want
to claim what I'm doing is like
Neuroscience
um one fun kind of day-to-day difference
is just it is so much easier to do
experiments on a neural network than a
brain I can just
to figure out what's going on a brain
you need to stab in electrodes and you
might kill your patients and irbs often
disapprove of this and you often need to
cut things open and
have careful hand washing procedures and
it sounds like a mess
while we're the neural network I can
just say
this is a computer program I will run it
I don't know what the computer program
does but I know what each of the steps
is even if the step is just multiplied
enormous vector by an even more enormous
Matrix and get out of new vexer I can
just save every intermediate thing that
I get when I'm running this model
and I can even
insert at some specific point in the
model let's replace these five entries
in that Vector with another five numbers
and then look at what happens
yeah right so it's much easier to do
experiments on digital neural networks
than actual or physical neural networks
AKA brains but um when when you're doing
these experiments
how does how does it actually work are
you are you
sometimes running a an AI model can be
very expensive and require a super
computer but when you're doing these
experiments you say that there's a tight
feedback loop so I assume that you're
running them rather quickly so you're
running parts of a network or how does
that work
sure so there's two important things to
clarify here there's the difference
between training and inference and the
difference between and the question of
how big the model you're working on is
so
um when when machine learning models are
made there's this stage called training
where
sorry models are made up of parameters a
very long list of numbers that determine
exactly what the model does
and then it's given an input and it
produces some output based on these
parameters and during training you give
the model a massive pile of data it
keeps looking at a data points but
current parameters it makes a guess for
say what the label of this image is or
what the next word is on this text and
then I get some feedback on whether it
was right or wrong and updates every
parameter to be a little bit closer to
what would have given it the right
answer
and you do this a really really long
time
and at the end of this by Blackmagic you
have parameters that are good at the
task even at the start the parameters
were just randomly generated numbers
and this is really slow really hard
really expensive
um and importantly the parameters are
being changed iteratively to become
better
and then at inference you've got you
just fixed the parameters
and he's given it and you look at the
outputs and this is much faster and
cheaper
um so for example gpd3 I believe was
chained on hundreds to thousands of gpus
um and running g53 is a bit of a
headache because it's just
such a big model it's got 200 billion
well 175 billion parameters uh generally
these models are run on gpus and
most gpus like the
expensive gpus can maybe hold
uh 20 billion numbers so you just need
to spread it across a bunch of things
and it's kind of a headache
but it's like much easier and faster if
you're doing inference and generally
when interpreting a model I'm taking a
train already trained model that people
are using and then trying to treat it as
this alien organism that I want to
investigate
and yes that's truly versus inference
yeah maybe we could we could because you
you describe these models as working by
blackmatic or being alien beings so I I
think that's actually key because what
you're trying to do is understand this
alien being by interpreting Yeah by
interpreting it do you feel like you're
working with something that's truly
alien from you or how do you how do you
feel when you're when you're trying to
interpret these models
alien is a weird word
I think when I hear the word alien it
connotes something like
fundamentally unknowable or bizarre and
mysterious
and my current Vibe about networks is
networks are weird but that they
fundamentally make sense given their
constraints
but that constraints are very different
from my constraints
in particular the way I think about the
world and the way I think many people do
especially on the technical side is kind
of logic and abstractions and I don't
know I write code and the code has all
of these if this then that but
everything in this list do blah blah
blah statements and it's all kind of
very formal precise
um while
internally networks are built on linear
algebra they have numbers that just kind
of take on a any real value they aren't
just like zero or one
and they're being multiplied together
and there's this whole Rich mathematical
theory of linear algebra the how you
should think about this and this just
heavily changes what kind of algorithms
are natural to express
um I also want to emphasize that
when I'm discussing algorithms I'm
mostly focusing on what it's natural to
implement kind of on the parameter level
of the model rather than what the
internal experience of the model might
be like
if that's even a meaningful phrase which
plausibly it isn't
what do you mean by internal experience
I I we're not discussing Consciousness
here how would you differentiate these
two things
so it's like when I'm personally
thinking
it often feels like I'm doing this
intuitive reasoning
that I'm not going through an explicit
formal reasoning process
but I'm kind of weighing up evidence
I've got this gut feel this especially
holds when I'm doing something that's
fairly intuitive like if I'm talking to
someone there's normally a part in my
mind tracking hmm is this person annoyed
with me are they enjoying themselves do
they look happy
and they're not running an ex it doesn't
internally feel like I'm running an
Express algorithm but I also have no
idea how my brain is implemented and
very plausibly there's some kind of
algorithm in there and there's kind of
these three separate things of how I
think about algorithms as Neil how my
brain might Implement an algorithm and
how a model May Implement an algorithm
and these are all pretty different
things
uh inductive bias is the jargon for this
the what ideas and algorithms is it
natural to be expressed in a model
one concrete example of this is so one
of my main projects as an independent
researcher has been this work on
grocking where I was reverse engineering
a model trained to do modular Edition
um kind of clock arithmetic like 11 plus
5 Mod 12 is 4 because it wraps around
when it gets bigger than 12.
um and to me modular arithmetic is
basically about you do addition and then
if it gets bigger than the modulus you
just like make it smaller an addition I
think of through an algorithm like
uh the kind of things you learn in
primary school just add the digits carry
the one add the tens carry the one Etc
and maybe a network would learn
something like binary Edition because
that's what's natural for a computer
but it turns out the model has learned
this whole while algorithm involving
triggered entities and Fourier
transforms
where what it's basically decided to do
is to rather than thinking about modular
audition as numbers that eventually wrap
around
it's thinking about numbers say
uh mod 12 as rotations of uh some number
of twelfths around the unit circle
and it's learned to combine these
rotations
so
uh let me know how whether I've lost you
this it's getting in the weeds no it's
it's interesting what so what you're
saying is uh to summarize it's invented
or
it solves a problem that we would solve
with simple math using very advanced
math or at least more advanced math and
this is a surprise to us what's
interesting to me here is that we are
surprised because what you're describing
is that on a on some level we understand
very well what's going on with neural
networks we have the math we have we
understand how computers work but still
we're surprised at what they come up
with and so there's some there's in some
sense we we understand what's going on
in some sense these networks aren't
alien to us but in another sense that we
can be genuinely surprised by how they
solve problems
yes one way to frame it is kind of
learning just another way of thinking
like what is it natural to express in
this network
where for me thinking about modular
addition as rotations is really weird
though it does technically work
like if you rotate by seven twelfths
around a circle and then rotates by
eight twelfths
that's 15 twelfths but because you've
wrapped around that's just three
twelfths
seven plus eight is three mods twelve
this is a valid way of thinking about it
but
uh it turns out that these geometric
Transformations are just much easier for
a model to express because you can
express all of this in terms of vectors
and matrices which are the natural
language of a model
and a lot of what has felt to me like
the skill in learning mechanistic
interpretability is learning to think in
what kind of things a model might
Express
I've actually been involved in this
great work with someone I'm mentoring
called Bilal triptai
um am I butchering his name sorry Bilal
and we recently wrote this paper looking
at how models look at groups in general
and I think a pretty functions briefly
earlier it uses this Arab math called
representation Theory
which basically extends this thing of
rotations around the unit circle to
geometric transformations of much larger
groups of like much higher dimensional
spaces like we found that a model had
learned to think about geometric
transformations of a four-dimensional
tetrahedron
and like what
but if your natural thing is linear
algebra this is a kind of reasonable
thing to express
do you find yourself developing an
intuition for how how AI models think so
to speak so do you do you begin to think
the way that we might imagine that they
think in terms of where everything is is
ultimately based on linear linear
algebra and binary
so I do want to just disentangle
how a neural network might think in the
terms of how my brain implements
neuronspiring and synapses and
neurotransmitters and all of that crap
and how a network thinks in terms of my
internal experience of sometimes having
these intuitions sometimes doing formal
mathematical reasoning
having a conversation Etc
and
I don't even know if networks have
something analogous to my intuition and
internal experience let alone wanting to
claim the field is anywhere near being
able to understand this
and
though hopefully it will be something
that seems kind of important
um what I'm referring to is much more
the mechanistic stuff of
how a model could Implement some
specific algorithm it is doing
like check whether the name gas appeared
in the past if it appeared look at what
came next and assume that's what's going
to come next
or
apply two rotations to each other to get
modular addition and weird things of
that form
is there a danger that AI models will
try to solve problems in very complex
ways that are natural for them but that
we cannot understand so can it become
way too advanced for us to to interpret
and and understand because it's easier
for formula for AI models to solve
problems in a specific way
so this is definitely an issue which I
honestly just don't really know
like interpreting models is hard but I
wouldn't say that we're good enough at
it but I could tell the difference
between we aren't good enough and it's
just impossible
I'm honestly a lot more concerned models
will learn a thing that isn't kind of
logical and is just a massive soup of
statistical correlations that turns out
to look like sophisticated Behavior but
which we have no hope of interpreting
and then it learns um Galaxy brains
algorithm that's just too hard for me to
understand but is in principle
interpretable
just like I'm so much happier if we live
in the second world uh if only because
that makes it tractable to maybe make
simpler systems that are near human that
we can understand and then use these to
help us understand the
like inscrutable alien brains which do
have internal structure
what I'm imagining here is a
self-driving car for example or a robot
navigating the world and I'm I'm
thinking that this is extremely complex
and then if we're trying to interpret
what's going on in a network like that
is it ever is it even approachable
because
who knows what's what's been developed
in training right it could be extremely
complex involving all sorts all sorts of
things that we that we have trouble in
uh untangling
so I think that's two things to
distinguish here so I often uh think
about what's happening in the model in
terms of these two concepts uh features
and circuits
so a feature is some property of the
inputs the model is detecting for
example this word is a noun or this is
the second word in Eiffel Tower
and a circuit is
a kind of some actual computation or
reasoning
uh reasoning in the mechanistic sense
not in the internal experience sense but
the model is learning how to do like
if I am looking for
um a city and I recently had a big
European Landmark appear look for the
city that came in
which is the kind of thing that a model
uses to answer the Eiffel Tower is in
with Paris
and
yeah I think that there's the question
of do models learn weird inscrutable
circuits some incredibly complicated
algorithm I have no hip of understanding
but where kind of the outputs and
internal representations kind of make
sense
and it seems like okay it's if we can
find a way to figure out what the
features represented are I'm pretty
happy
and that there's does it learn
weird alien abstractions about the world
that we have no hope of understanding
like how if you train to model in the
late 1800s uh in some hypothetical uh
steampunk World it might learn to reason
out the world through quantum mechanics
and
that does not seem like a thing that I
would trust my ability to reverse
engineer
uh but that would be such a great story
if people had discovered quantum
mechanics by reverse engineering and AI
trains to model physics
do you think something like that could
actually happen with us could could it
be the case that uh say future Advanced
AIS will will help us understand physics
or chemistry in a deeper way than we
understand it now
by and I'm thinking that the star here
would be that it's that the model
discovers something and we reverse
engineer it and then develop better
theory is that is that plausible too
so yeah there's this idea called
microscope AI from Chris Ola which is
basically this idea that okay
making
AI that can do complex human level tasks
seems really useful but also absolutely
terrifying and we have no real reason to
think these models are actually going to
do what we want and if there's one thing
I've learned from the field of AI
elements it's that we do not know how to
align these things
uh so what if rather than making a thing
that acts in the world we just make a
thing but never turn it on and just try
to dissect its brain and reverse
engineer what it's learned and what kind
of thought processes it has and then
just either learn just understand these
for the value of understanding them and
the understanding it brings or try to
make some simpler thing that implements
these algorithms
and
I
think and Chris would have I believe
Chris would agree with me that this is
not actually a thing that's likely to
happen before we get things that are
just capable of acting in the world and
doing things and this being way more
useful but it's a fun romantic image
definitely romantic image true and if
we're in a world where we actually make
human level Ai and it is aligned with
what we want
and we need to figure out what humanity
is placed in a bod like that is I
definitely hope that we're able to
understand science and ideas from these
systems
even if
I know it is probably strictly easier to
have a system that can explain the
scientific concept that it understands
to a human in an understandable way than
to reverse engineer it Could you um
could you take mechanistic
interpretability and then place it into
the larger context of AI safety where
does it fit into the broader research
field that is AI safety
sure so
the broader field of AI safety is kind
of a mess and there's lots of different
people who have very different views on
the problem and how to go about solving
it as is good and how the world should
be for as confusing and Messier problem
as AI alignments
um a couple of important axes along with
which people vary
there's the school of people who work on
prosaic AI alignments meaning
we want to figure out how we would align
a human level system built on current
day techniques
and the fields there focuses this can
just mean neural networks and deep
learning but practically nowadays it
normally means looking at large language
models like Chad gbt and thinking about
what a human level system built on this
kind of Technology might look like
and I would say that most mechanistic
interpretability work fits into that
category of trying to really engage with
these models
and understand how to reverse engineer
those
another big dividing question is
empirical work versus conceptual work
and a kind of underlying question about
the importance of feedback loops where
you get these people who are working
with these large models or otherwise
working on reality planning systems even
if there's some more toy and trying to
model parts of the alignment problem and
figure out how you might solve it in
practice
and then there's all sorts of people who
are thinking through what are the threat
models we might care about what are the
ways that an AI might actually be
dangerous
um what kinds of solutions could we come
up with and do these work in do these
work on a conceptual level
and there are researchers like um Evan
tubinger and Paul kashan Islamic
Research Center but I can do some pretty
solid work here
but there's one of the really hard Parts
about doing conceptual work is having
feedback groups and having the ability
to distinguish between
are you doing things that are correct
and Truth tracking or have you gone off
into your vast castle in the Clouds of
pretty philosophical Concepts that don't
matter
how pre yeah so the AI safety field as a
whole do you think it lacks a unified
Paradigm is it is it kind of uh how to
what extent this AI safety still
fumbling around trying to find something
a base to build on or a unifying
Paradigm on which all researchers can
can agree on the basics and say that you
know quantum mechanics is such a
paradigm in physics how far are we from
such a paradigm in AI safety
sure so
I would at least somewhat argue that we
don't really have a paradigm for deep
learning at least in the sense of no one
already knows what's going on
so argue with it is a paradigm in terms
of how you make gpus go Burr and produce
systems that are better
uh which sadly is much easier than
making systems we understand or which
do what we want
um and I would say that the field of a
element definitely does not feel to me
like it has a clear paradigm I would say
that mechanistic interpretability it
feels like it's converging a little bit
more on a paradigm or at least a shared
set of methods and techniques and
philosophies
but also that there's lots of people
lots of very different opinions
um I've recently been reading Thomas
Coons the structure of scientific
revolutions which I believe is the
origin of this Paradigm notion and lots
of the things he refers to like
researchers bitterly arguing about the
right techniques to use and the right
way to interpret evidence I definitely
Vibe with
but I also want to challenge a bit the
framing of the question where
to me I feel like when I hear Paradigm
this connotation that this is good and
what you want
and I feel like it's easy to have a
incorrect overly restrictive paradigm
and I think that it's good and important
there to be some Metric by which you can
measure progress
not necessarily an explicit metric like
a benchmark but just a kind of agreed
upon set of norms and principles to
evaluate whether this work is good or
not
and what are the problems you want to
work towards but I think it's also very
easy to get really caught up in specific
paradigms
for example a lot of uh eleazkowski and
Nick bostrom's early work on AIX risk is
built on these specific Frameworks
around expected utility maximizers and
um
kind of sovereigns who are modeled as
these omnipotent things who can just act
on the world
and just are smart so they can do
whatever they want I'm caricature but I
think there's lots of aspects of this
that just don't match our understanding
of modern deep learning and I think the
field could coalesce around that
Paradigm that like could actually be bad
my ideal is probably a field with like
maybe three robust paradigms and then a
long tail of people trying to make their
own paradigm
so that
is like I know I think that the Paradigm
of
let's figure out how to interpret how to
align gpt3
or Chachi BT or tpt4 Etc
how to make these systems do what we
want
and go from that to eventual AGI seems
like I thought the highest priority
thing and I think that could be a
paradigm forming around that that would
feel pretty good to me but I never
wanted to be the entirety of the field
because we're trying to speculate about
this future technology and what could go
wrong with it that is not the kind of
thing where you should have consensus
and perhaps as you as you mentioned
paradigms could be could become overly
um restrictive and also maybe it would
be too slow for for a very fast moving
field such as AI to try to develop an
overarching a paradigm if you think
about how long it took for us to develop
these paradigms in in physics we're
talking uh decades to centuries and
perhaps we do not have that kind of time
in in the field of AI
so
I think there's lots of different things
that you can mean when you say forming a
paradigm and a particular trying to form
a paradigm that it's worth trying to
disentangle
I think that forming a consensus is a
very hot
kind of
Adeno science moves on one funeral at a
time is the classic saying the way you
form a consensus is where the old God
who believes something else just like
retire or die and that takes agents
um but that doesn't feel to me like the
key thing here to me the thing that are
like a researcher in the fields job is
not necessarily building a consensus
it's trying to
articulate ideas trying to take everyone
else's work and distill it into a
cohesive worldview trying to iterate on
the right techniques and the right
toolkit trying to critique other
people's work and find flaws in other
techniques
until you slowly red team your way to a
good technique and toolkit that actually
works
and to me these are core parts of
forming a paradigm that also core parts
of just doing good research
and one of the things I found really fun
about doing mechanistic interactability
versus say pure maths is there's this
wild forest of open questions
um one of my recent side projects has
been writing the sequence called 200
concrete open problems in mechanistic
interpretability as a fun challenge to
myself to just
that's too many can I write down 200
and I probably wrote down more than 200.
so when when I hear you speak about this
it sounds like you have a pretty well
developed
um world view on AI safety and perhaps
we could we could you wouldn't you
wouldn't say like that it you seem to
have formed
um your own beliefs about this could you
could you spend a little time talking
about how you got here so how do you
have these independent beliefs you have
a a sense of what's important a sense of
what's interesting to a large extent
than than most people I would I would
think
sure so I think one caveat worth giving
before I jump into this is the
difference between having beliefs that
are true in the sense that they track
true things about the world
and
um like if you look back in 100 years
when we kind of know what actually
happened how correct am I on this Cosmic
scorecard and then there's have beliefs
that feel true to me
have
yeah have things that make sense have
things where
it just feels true and I understand how
it works oh maybe this breaks down to
two things there's confidence which is
what I've been describing of
you know how you believe you know how it
works and it feels reliable and
reassuring
and then there's
um having a model of it with moving
Parts where you don't just know AI risk
matters because Elias yodkowski said so
and he's really smart but it's more okay
uh air is masses because models might be
trained with reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning might give them
goals there's no reason the goals need
to be good and where you kind of have
this chain of reasoning that you can
interrogate and where you know what
would happen if you change your mind on
different parts of it
and I think that people often conflate
the being confident with the truth
tracking
I think I have done much better on the
being confident than on the truth
tracking which is potentially concerning
and I do think I've done reasonably well
on the forming a model with moving parts
uh the jargon and a lemon circus is
often having a gears level model
um and I'm very happy to talk about that
but I thought this is a framing worth
giving
definitely please tell us about your
gears level
um model of of how AI safety Works
especially I would be interested in how
do we go from doing mechanistic
interpretability to actually
decreasing the risk of uh or decreasing
AI risk or existential risk I think my
processible means beliefs was not
particularly sophisticated a little bit
just kind of happened naturally over
time I read arguments I thought the
arguments were broadly reasonable I
talked to people I tried to come up with
arguments against what I've been reading
um I just spent time working in the
fields being exposed to different
viewpoints And discussing research and
critiquing other people's research and
probably I could have optimized much
harder for forming like really great
deep beliefs on this but
a lot of it just kind of happens
naturally I think in the past I was very
stressed about finding the one true form
of beliefs about AI alignments and the
one true agenda that was the most
important I think this is just like
essentially impossible for as
complicated and controversial a question
about as AI alignments
many smartcoms and people don't even
think it's an issue at all
even if I tragically really come across
well-reasoned arguments from those
people
and
uh though I have recently seen some good
good attempts on that front
and
yeah I have this post called uh concrete
advice for reviews on AI safety which
people should go check out if they want
more of my tics
um the core of it is just this
incremental things will kind of happen
over time expose yourself to things
I've also a really big believer in
trying to summarize and distill other
people's beliefs
like take an argument or an article or a
researchy respects and try to distill
down their arguments or beliefs to a
kind of bullet points or tree structure
where you see their beliefs and how they
depend on the previous ones
I think that
just doing this even if you aren't
trying that hard to evaluate how much
you agree with each step in the tree is
really helpful performing a model with
moving parts so obviously figuring out
what you actually think about it and
trying to critique it is a great part of
the process
uh moving to the second bit of your
question on how I think mechanistic
interpretability fits into the big
picture
so
partially I don't know
I a lot of why I feel satisfied about
working on mechanistic interpretability
is that a it's just really really fun
and I seem good at this and I've just
it's grabbed me so much more than the
other areas of alignment I tried
um I think there is something to be said
for just if there's lots of things that
seem pretty good work on the thing that
you think you are comparatively best at
and part of what makes the risk of us
part of me feel satisfied is I think
that
if we understood more about what was
going on in potential
human level black box systems that are
shaping the world and potentially
following goals we don't want
seems like yes obviously understanding
them will help how could it possibly not
help
and that my work is not relying on a
specific fragile argument where if I
change my mind about some key assumption
everything comes Crashing Down
um I do think there are key assumptions
but most of them are the empirical and
scientific questions of will any of this
work
um with maybe a side serving of will
this net be helpful for making the
system safer rather than understanding
them just letting us make them better
and faster which is another thing that I
think anyone researching the stuff
should be thinking about
but yeah so once with all of this
caveats aside
um
I should occasionally give actual
answers instead of pure caveats
um one story that I find pretty
compelling
is that
so
it's very easy to give an input to an
air system and see its outputs and to
study its kind of overall Behavior
and often looking at behavior and
carefully choosing the inputs and
outputs can tell you a lot about the
system
but one of the times when this is
messiest
is when there are multiple Solutions
that both give
comparable or even identical outputs
and
one of the ways I think mechanistic
interpretability can really shine is if
you're trying to reverse engineer what
algorithms the model has learned
and there are multiple algorithms that
lead to the same behavior you should be
able to distinguish between these two
algorithms
and
the field is very much in early stages
but I was involved in this work I
mentioned earlier about reverse
engineering grocking where the model
learned the model was doing a task where
it both learned the solution of
memorizing it of just memorizing the
data scene and a solution about
generalizing data I hadn't seen
and mechanistic interpretability got a
lot of traction there but I think that
more broadly
one of the key bad scenarios I see is we
produce this competent
deceptive model which wants power and
influence
and which is competent enough that it
can deceive us and do exactly what an
aligned model would do
and this seems like a very very
important scenario where there are
multiple models where there are multiple
Solutions a model could be implementing
that have the same behavior
and I think that anything centered on
Deception
um seems like a really exciting way like
a really promising way for macintop to
do something useful
I further think that
there's like a lot of ways this could
cash out as being helpful and I go see
there as being a spectrum of how well we
succeed at doing mechanistic
interpretability where there's the world
we're kind of in now where with a lot of
laboratory with like months of laborious
effort from many researchers you might
be able to take a model like gp3 and
have some shot of noticing deception in
it even if it's very much not reliable
and this is like way better than nothing
if we're going to deploy a system into
the real world being able to do things
like coma through neurons and check
whether it's deceptive seems like a lot
better than nothing
but if we got better at this
um then ideally we could
um use this to like just reliably audit
systems and get as confident as we can
that they're good
I'm also really excited about this as a
path to get better feedback loops to
people doing the actual alignment work
like
if you try an alignment technique and
you want to figure out whether it works
if you could look at the deception
circuit and see how much this has
changed the models like how much the
model is lying or look at what goals the
model has internally represented if it's
represented gold at all and use this to
better understand and like use this to
check how all your Technique worked that
seems really exciting yeah yeah
definitely on a very basic level there's
so if we think about the alignment
problem we want to align AI values with
human values and of course we we need to
understand what are the AI values or the
AI goals and so on in some sense
mechanistic interpretability is very
obvious as an approach of course not the
content but that you would want to do
mechanistic interpretability seems very
straightforward to me or like an
essential part of aligning AI
I I should give the caveats that most of
the arguments I'm giving are not
actually
mechanistic interpretability specific
arguments they're why you should care
about interpretability in general
where interpretability is this pretty
large subfield of AI which mechanistic
interpretability is just like pretty
Niche but growing sub-area and
I got into mechanistic interpretability
because it just seemed by far the most
inspiring area in terms of forming what
I thought were actual true beliefs about
models and it's so so easy to shoot
yourself in the foot and trick yourself
into thinking you know what's going on
or former resurface level understanding
or an understanding which wouldn't
really generalize to a much larger more
sophisticated model
um such that I personally think
mechanistic interpretability is the best
bet to be making but this is very much
my personal take that people should not
take as the gospel on
the only way to do interruptability is
mechanistic interpretability where we
painstakingly look for specific circuits
and nothing else could work
perhaps we could talk a bit more about
this notion of an AI becoming deceptive
how how would that come about how would
an AI become deceptive and how would
interpretability or perhaps specifically
mechanistic interpretability help us
distinguish between an honest Ai and a
deceptive AI
sure so
there's a framework that I like a lot
but breaking down how to think about AIX
risk from this report by Joseph Carl
Smith the open philanthropy on power
seeking AI where he breaks down
three traits the system might have
there's
um which equals uh APS there's
um just Advanced capabilities a system
being human level or better in a lot of
important areas
um
no not necessarily all there's planning
which is the system is capable of
forming
um like real plans it has goals and it's
able to form plans towards those goals
you can also think of this as kind of it
is an agents whatever that word means
and strategic awareness which is
it kind of knows its context it knows it
is
a language model being trained by a
company called openai on the internet to
predict the next token or whatever
and the argument goes that if you have
all of these
that or most possible things a system
might want
assuming so assuming the system has
goals which comes onto this kind of
agentic planning assumption
then it's going there are generic things
like having power and resources and
money and autonomy that is really useful
towards these
unless you get exactly the right goals
this idea called instrumental
convergence
and so it's gonna want to do things like
say have it supervisors give it good
reward or not turn it off or release it
into the world
it's going to understand its context
it's going to understand it's got these
operators it's being trained in some way
that involves being given feedback and
it's going to have some understanding of
the mechanisms by which these work how
people work how people think what our
preconceptions are about an AI system
strategic awareness sounds kind of weird
and sci-fi-ish but if you just ask
Chachi PT what are you it just gives a
perfectly coherent answer I even asked
it to give me training code for a large
language model like itself and it gave
code that would basically have worked
with a little bit of editing uh though
uh fortunately not for the hard part of
trading it across thousands of gpus
um so models trained on the internet
definitely no one large language models
are and then yeah so it realizes that it
wants things it's easier to get things
if you can control what your operators
want
and knowing that you have operators
and is
important context of deciding that this
is worth doing
um like a system like alphago I don't
think is ever going to decide to see
those operators because it's trained to
play go I don't see it ever getting
strategic awareness about the real world
and then it has the advanced
capabilities to actually do this
so yeah to summarize
um having goals
planning towards these goals having the
awareness of its context such that it
realizes that deception is useful
and the instrumental convergence such
that deception is useful towards its
goals and doesn't heavily conflict with
them
and then being competent enough that I
can use its understanding of its context
to like successfully to see
but if we can figure out what's going on
inside these networks then we can
distinguish between deceptive deceptive
AIS and honest AIS
this is the Hope yes this is the hope
hopefully we can yes so I definitely do
not want to claim that this is a thing I
am confident we'll be able to do or that
mechanistic interpretability is
obviously the best path to do this
but I do think it is a the kind of thing
that I think mechanistic
interpretability could be the right tool
for
in particular
I think that
things around what goals does this model
have and what
kinds like what algorithms are following
for these actions are the kinds of
things I think mechanistic
interpretability is like targeting
um one particular thing that makes me
optimistic about this kind of angle is
that
one of the areas mechanistic
interpretability shines is by finding
thinking and computation the model does
that's very localized that's either
specific to some behavior and which is
specific to some components of the model
like some layers and some neurons
and which is not where like most of the
model just doesn't actually matter that
much
and
it's an open question to me about how
these models work
look whether this is this localization
is a true thing in general rather than
just the somewhat cherry-picked areas
the field I studied so far but it's
possible to me that the really important
things like goals there is some
semi-localized semi-explicit
representations
and it is plausible to me that but
something like deception we can look at
what kind of circuit internal circuitry
lights up in social situations look for
commonalities and try to reverse
engineer the key things there
and that most of the model is going
towards these generic capabilities like
understanding language modeling the
world's knowledge
but the these are much less relevant
from an element context even if those
are some things I care a lot about being
able to reverse engineer as well
it would be great for us if goals were
localized in the network because then we
can
we can find them we can isolate them and
we can easily understand them more
easily than than if they were say spread
across the entire network
yes